America's Tick-Tock dancing ex Chicago
Mayors go into the ivy league Lori
Lightfoot starting her new role as a
Harvard lecturer where she'll teach the
Next Generation how they too can ruin a
once great City through sheer and
competence
lightfoot's class will include a
simulated community meeting where you
can ignore the crime concerns of your
residents and there will be mock press
conferences where you can only pick on
reporters of color just like when Lori
said she would only Grant one-on-one
interviews to black and brown
journalists
when I look at it across this Podium as
I'm doing now I don't see much in the
way of diversity to suggest that somehow
I'm saying certain journalists are
racist really
no the facts are the facts
okay so um do you think people are
knocking each other over judge to take
this class in the fall
probably it's Harvard yeah it's Harvard
but you know what only at Harvard would
they would they have the doors wide open
for people who've been voted out of
office and think that they should be
teaching the next generation of
corporate um uh headquarter leaders uh
how to run a city how to run a
corporation remember Bill de Blasio did
a real mess in New York City is I
believe a lecture at Harvard but uh you
know dealing with the media I mean she
says I'll only talk to black and brown
people and not white people and by the
way how not to run a city carjacking
went up
204 while she was the mayor not 10 not
20. uh she's a mess Harold she's
teaching a course in health policy and
Leadership
where do you think she has those
credentials well we'll see I I'm a
little bit of a contrarian here I think
that people who lose campaigns are
people who have rocky 10 years when
they're in an executive office meaning
mayor Governor president may have
something to offer uh I think kids and
young people and those studying uh
public policy and public leadership I
hope ask her the very tough questions I
I'd love to go up and be maybe audit one
of the classes to hear some of the
smartest students in the country the
smartest students in the country ask
what did you do so wrong to make people
turn on you four years later do you
think it was crime do you think it was a
lack of Health Care and in a serious not
not not poking fun way but asking no no
what would you have done differently
because you you obviously ran on an
agenda and you didn't achieve the things
you wanted to achieve and do you blame
that on now in her answer maybe that she
blames everybody then I hope if you're a
student you say you know what that's not
the model I want you I hope she gives
some on it I hope she gives honest
answers take the question from you no
one else
for junior undercover to Harvard and see
what he gets I'm surprised at the media
not being shocked about this no I'm
kidding but okay so think about any
Republican who leaves an Administration
and goes to work for a an oil company or
a pharmaceutical company or lobbying for
something some sort of other big Auto
thing or something or Fox News Fox 100
right and then they'll say this is a
disgusting revolving door well what
happens in Liberal circles they all go
to Academia and you wonder why Americans
writ large are saying what is going on
with the problems with Academia today
also on this very day Harvard was named
worst school for free speech scoring
below zero after nine professors and
researchers face calls to be disciplined
or fired for voicing controversial
opinions this was done by the foundation
for individual rights and expression so
I think that it would be a great
question to put to her to say do you
regret saying you would only take
questions from reporters based on their
skin color for that day do you regret
that because it set her off on that was
kind of the beginning of the end of her
tenure Greg Gutfeld all right this is
weird a picture I thought she had a
career in modeling I that's fire f-i-r-e
oh I said I go is that fire she goes no
it's you said no it's foundation for
individuals
that's the best thing ever you know um
in this in this landscape of Decay every
incompetent leftist has a six-figure or
seven figure safety net right and any
squad member that exits Congress will
have a seat on some board of a company
because you need to do that your life is
set unlike you I mean if you go to the
capital and you capital on January 6th
and you wear a funny hat you go to jail
but if you preside over say the mass
murder of young blacks in the city while
it's extolling racist principles and the
worst victim culture in history you get
Plum seats at a university and lucrative
speaking gigs that's how it works
Liberty University has said if anything
happens to you here at Fox there is a
plum teaching assignment waiting for you
Jesse
I got a call from Devry
they are willing to give you a seat
really yes at DeVry
I shouldn't want that
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else